Organisations have been generating
data since way back
But as time goes on, more & more
data is being generated.
IBM estimates that 90% of world's data
was created in the last two years alone.
This is a simple example.
Think of your cellphone.
Whenever your cellphone is turned on,
it's connected to the cell towers.
As you move around,
it'll connect to different towers
in a different signal streaks.
All of that connection data is collected
by the phone company & it's being logged.
They can use that information to find
dead spots in the coverage
& know which towers are busiest &
need increased capacity.
They can even trace you if you make an
emergency phone call but
don't get your exact location.
This is an enormous amount
of data we have.
Another example as when you visit a
website like Amazon or Netflix,
everything, you do there is logged: what
pages you view, how long you spend there,
where you coming from.
They can even capture things like what
browser you are using.
Again this is a huge amount of data.
Phone data & website logs are just examples.
In addition, things like X-rays are
creating huge amounts of data.
& people doing research to detect
similarities in tumors.
The increase in amount of data we're
generating opens up huge possibilities.
But it comes with problems too.
Where do we've to store all this data?
& process it too?